okay hello everyone this is my third
live stream today
all right new topic uh this is welcome
language design review incremental
language development
and we are looking first at threaded a
new a new capability oh we're reviewing
documentation for that okay
and we're actually going to be able to
review threaded in the in the wild
okay
so i think the main thing here is that
this is a such a special creature
and so
its documentation is also a bit special
i think one thing to start mentioning
with this our documentation of listable
is non-existent to appalling
i mean
we know what we mean by listable but but
i
think users get quite confused by it
um
i don't like using this as an adjective
we should say for any function f
with attribute listable or something or
with listable with a
you know just a word
um
so are there any design issues here
i mean are you are you asking for help
in in the documentation or
i mean i don't know if there are
diagrams that would help here
um
so the diagrams so we're trying to
explain the second argument of threaded
and
and because it refers to a level of the
other array we have these diagrams
there are four diagrams there in which
we try to align the level at which we
represent the threading
that's the double arrow there
gosh yeah these are things that would
tim would have to have a whack at but
is there any tension
tensor
index notation that would be helpful
there are examples further down
comparing for example with table
in in properties and relations we have
several examples don't don't do matrix
form
really don't do that initially don't do
that initially you can do it as a second
example but this is plenty useful
without
matrix form
makes sense
if
which matrix form are you objecting to
both both
i would i would just do it look i would
do this i would do
um
i always have to check how the uh
you know
what matrix four means like how the
lists map to the columns and rows and so
on
i would just do that that should be the
first example
in my opinion in fact i'll even put it
in if you want
sure put it in
i'm not going to put in the words yet
but but um
i mean don't get
i don't know this is crazy to show that
i mean
no
i mean no
those are way way way too complicated
i mean you should show this
you should show the fact that it
um
maybe you should show one
where
um
you could show by comparison you could
show a b
well actually what you could show is a b
c d
plus x y
there
showing that it's different
and then you can go on and show
you know maybe you want to do something
where we go
um
maybe what we want is actually one two
lag
three four five six
and then we show
well we can't show plus x y but then we
show plus threaded
you know simple things like that
um
perhaps that's the best initial example
to show
yeah i think with the def different f
dimensions is is better to show
yeah
maybe okay so but then here
maybe what we want to do is to take that
thing
and show that you have to add
x y z to it
and so on okay then then
um
well let's see the
i mean that's basically the example
that's already there right only
you don't have to have
the idea of matrices which not everybody
is into
right i think that um
i mean
this idea of rows and columns we should
have next a little bit later maybe we
should have one at slightly higher depth
first then we should go to that one
and that's not even close that's an
application example of some kind yeah
i'll move that to applications
um
okay now in terms of tensor arithmetic
well okay first first question is is
this
are you are you done with the
implementation rob
the implementation is is done except for
the
the sort of packed array numeric ray
part which is still
still being worked on
um you know mark mark is going through a
whole bunch of stuff in the runtime
library which is necessary to get this
done correctly so but it's still you
know that it still works
if the inputs are packed array it just
doesn't do it optimally efficiently
does it unpack it or
it it partially unpacks so if you add a
big matrix to a big vector with threaded
it unpacks down one level
um and it's about a factor of two slower
than it absolutely needs to be
okay so let me understand
okay
you know
i don't think this is the right way to
document this
okay
first of all i think this should be
i think it should say
yeah i mean we i just want to say for
the record it's not that we haven't
thought about it it's that it's not so
easy to figure out what the right way to
say it is
yeah i understand
yeah exactly and i was going to say you
know
first thing is threaded of
list
represents
doesn't it need to be an array
well i was thinking okay derivative
array
represents
an array
to be
threaded
into the lowest level
of
when combined with a listable function
or you know yeah but
you're running the same problem i did
okay okay hold on but i do think that
what you want to do here
um represents an array
represents an object
let's try something like this
so if we say
if we said something like this because
it is always a list
i mean that's
okay and then we said something like
okay here's a possible term threaded
edition
threads
add
the elements of list
into array
in a threaded
fashion
uh
sound right uh
but they're both kinds of threading
right i mean this is
i mean i think we'd want to say
something adds the elements to the
lowest level of array or something like
that yeah okay level
it seems like the first thing this needs
to communicate is what the difference is
between this and thread
yeah and it represents an object
i mean jose pointed out an interesting
thing about the threadref page that we
say that it threads but we never
actually define what thread means
it's just in a long time
but we just do it in quotes well i know
that that's that's that's a typical
thing that we did and it's probably the
best one could do because it's better
you know when you give a kind of
mathematical definition it's it's often
incomprehensible to people
you know like like you know this first
example is fairly easy to understand but
the mathematical version of that
gets comparably difficult
well but i mean that's what the details
are for i know i know
the details are fine to have mathematics
in but i don't think we should have the
very first
um
that very first line was trying
precisely to
showcase the the most important case i
know
but i think it will be hard for people
to understand with indices i think
they'll look at the examples to find
sort of an index-like version
represent as an object
well by the way i think thread doesn't
even in its details doesn't even explain
what it does
right yeah that's sort of the point
exactly an object development is listed
automatically threaded the lowest level
will be automatically threatened lowest
level in array
when
when used in list listable operations
when used in operations
by the way
it should say very early on here
it should say
um
in
array plus threaded
of list
the lowest level dimension
of array
must
match
the
the length of list
i don't know if we say that
oh but that's that's only correct if
list is a vector
okay
i mean that the more full statement is
the lowest level dimensions of array
must match the
dimensions of list
okay i think we should try to get some
diagrams of what this thing does
um yeah well those excluded cells for
one one attempt to sort of explain how
the stability and threaded works
which i think if they're timified they
wouldn't be so bad and then those other
diagrams that i put in were something
jose and i discussed that try to explain
where the dimensions match
i mean they're they're not nice because
i'm not good at type settings
i'm not keen on x and y as being the
yellow the different things
i'm not really even keen on using f i
would just use plus and then say it can
be generalized to f
because i think plus is going to be the
very common case
um sometimes yes it's also important to
say that um
uh it can be either way around and it's
also important do i know if you discuss
this to talk about the case where there
are three arguments things like this
right so i mean if i say threaded of
this plus
i mean i have an example in that that
shows that in the scope section
okay
what happens by the way if you just say
good question
that does the right thing
you should show that in somewhere in
some scope section i'm pretty sure
that's shown in the scope section as
well
something to take into account here is
that when what we are threading is an
array with several levels then we are
not just threading a level it we are
threading all levels right then object
elements will automatically be threaded
into the lowest level array
um
please don't use x and y
just don't use x and y
it's like super confusing
it's like those are coordinates not
things
okay
we're going to use a and b for example
that's fine or yeah
and i wouldn't use that right a1 and r2
r being a
r i think i think we can just use and b
probably is okay
just not x and y
um
i mean this should surely
say a lev to be love
there
yes
but i also think i strongly think
that it should be
yeah fair enough
because i think it's going to be by far
the dominant case is plus threaded
i think you've got those two mixed up it
should be
b left goes to a level
it's a confusing thing but it all
canonicalizes to the one level
one level specification which is a
fortunate thing
how does it do that
well because one once you
by requiring that b be an array then we
can always
adjust to one
you know one goes to lev which is the
the one argument specification for live
without the rule
i see i see i see i see
i see by the way you should also say
that that basically this is a creature
of um and if i make this
ragged i'm out of luck
that's right
[Music]
lost and found
you need a message
yeah i i think there is one but i'll
i'll have to be sure
yeah i mean yeah as a friday i put in
the messages but maybe i didn't push
them soon enough or something okay fair
enough
um
what lovely functionality this is
now
i have a question i mean are there any
other
kind of structures like quantity array
or something that should be able to take
threaded
well quantity array is effectively doing
its own threading already it's
unthreaded
and i think there is an example further
down
if quantity had a listable attribute
then quantity of threaded would be
equivalent to quantity array
i think it's near the very end probably
yeah this this one
well should quantity have listable
attribute
i mean i i i'm sure there's existing
stuff that sort of relies on having
like quantity of vectors without it
distributing but
well no
i mean
quantity effectively
threats
as if it was listable now the thing is
what happens if we want to have a list
in the first argument and a list in the
second argument
that's why it can't be listable
right then then i mean at the moment i
don't think it it supports that syntax
but if we wanted to support that syntax
the listable attribute would force that
would force us into a corner yeah right
but i mean it could be effectively okay
you're saying
okay wait a minute
if i i'm just trying to think of other
uses of threaded
that aren't directly on
well uh
look i think i mean already this plus
thing is just
huge
um
well that's probably enough i mean i'm
just wondering whether like span and
things like that
they will end up or up to they will end
up getting all kinds of different
sort of additional
things
um
there's nothing with partition or with
what about with um
uh with things like padding uh like like
um arraypad and so on
well i see that you are
trying to use threaded inside functions
that are not listable yes so the
interesting thing is what
is threaded going to be used for with
things like mathematical functions which
are all listable
i i cannot see where the users will
i cannot predict i mean i'm sure they
would use it but how i don't know really
see already i mean okay so let's say
threaded
what will happen
i'm so confused what this will do
i don't even know what the heck this
will do okay so let's describe
a bunch of different bezel functions of
different orders at the at the specific
points
yep
i think we do need to work out
um
um
kind of the calculus of a map thread
versus threaded versus whatever
just to understand because i don't
really understand i mean maybe there's
some weird thing you can do with outer
and things like that with threaded
i don't think we thought those things
through yet but we have explored that
already a bit in the examples that are
there there are comparisons with inner
for example this is a very interesting
comparison of threaded with inner things
a bit farther up
um
yes
this one
do you really want to do that set
attributes f listable why don't you just
do plus
we can it's just a way of showing more
generality but yeah we can do more plus
um
okay
a plus threaded of v
well so you're basically saying you
don't need enough
because you can just do that's much
nicer way of doing you know
yes
in in a sense yes so the the point is
that there are some of our functions
which already thread at the deepest
level like dot or inner
neatly connected to to thread it
i see
and what about map thread
map thread threads at the top level
so it's
it's
combining map thread with threaded is
that meaningful or am i confused though
well we had discussed or i had proposed
at some point to generalize map threat
to take negative third arguments to do a
bit of what else
thread that would do from outside
now unfortunately the connection with
inner breaks
we when there is an and a third ah sorry
a second argument in threaded we need a
transposition it's an interesting thing
but
you see the next lines are a bit more
complicated
by the way that might be nice more
nicely represented with arrows maybe not
not if it's that transposition my
gosh um
the heck is that transposition
like gosh it's moving three levels
yeah
um
okay
the last one could be written with two
ray rule i think
um
yes
yeah
um
okay
sandra is commenting let's see subtract
to center data
yeah so multiply scaling vectors and
different scalings in different
directions yes absolutely
i mean so
the use case there
well i mean we can just do that with a
constant array
um
so oh this is very beautiful i mean we
can just do this
i i'm some reason i'm not getting used
to it yet with uh without
uh less baby
might be nice to detect that case and
give a more sentient message
might also be
right
for some reason the times thing feels a
lot less natural than the plus thing
give me another listable
function that i might plausibly use this
with
power
very exciting in this case but let's say
that's how you can construct like a
design matrix is with
look at that go wrong
yeah
okay what are some other examples where
what about an image processing or there
are obvious examples there
well i gave that that that that example
you didn't like as a basic one was an
image that's that i think is the
classic case for image processing very
nice we're going to scale the colors
i would not do it for a 3d image
my god
i mean
if again that'll yeah we can we can we
can do a 2d image one too
right but i do like that i do like that
scaling colors
it's a good example
um
it's actually one thing that is nice
this is for like a
you know some properties and relations
or something but the fact that if you
did that with map
you would have to write it differently
depending on whether it was a 2d or 3d
image but with threaded it's the same
yes that's a good point i should put
both in the same example to emphasize
that yes i guess maybe you could use
some negative level spec but yeah
it's still messy
you know this is a good construct but it
is also a cautionary tale because it
shouldn't have taken us 35 years to
invent this construct
yes
um
i feel like we're doing some things now
with this you know unevaluated
expressions and this and that and the
other where we're
where we're kind of
it wasn't threaded part of a larger
story about a raise or did we manage to
basically boil everything we wanted to
do with the raise down to threaded no
this this was a this is a part of a much
bigger discussion about arrays and this
was this was our
our answered as sort of whole questions
about broadcasting and stuff in python
which which allows people to do
these sorts of operations well because
they have the opposite definition of
listable
yes well it's it's it's
it's a slightly more amorphous
definition of listable but yes
but
i think that erase stuff by the way is
theoretically coming back but it's sort
of been waiting for
for someone to like i think in principle
it's hap there's going to be another
meeting at some point but yeah well okay
the future of array project has branched
into two pieces
one is the uh data container thing
and the other
i thought was these array operations
like threaded
is there more is there more than that in
there
i don't think so no
okay but so
but there's nothing beyond threaded
there's no other
kind of
array index manipulation thing that we
have in the plan
well
i mean there's sort of the opposite
direction of you know telling things not
to list right of the scissors oh yeah
yeah yeah right right the vector yes we
did talk about that the concept of a
of a d d list ability
yes we talked about that we need to
cover that so that needs to be in
another meeting yeah rob
you know rob has some rough prototype i
don't know if it's really
you know well you use stuff in in your
in a bunch of of calculus functions
right they're these horrifying
you know element of vectors too and
things like this
right
rob do you want to think about that
right so we have a we have a somewhat
different design which which you know
we've discussed with jose and me and
roger which we think is and the idea
um you know i want to go too far into
this because it's you know it's a big
topic it's a i mean threaded is a
relatively easy change compared to this
this this other thing but but we've
talked about introducing something
called a like a symbolic say a symbolic
vector so you'd set x equal to a
symbolic vector
and then it's treated as not a scalar
and we need you know to make it look
reasonable we need
type setting for that so it looks like
uh you know annotated x
well it doesn't look like a horrible
thing
call it vector
we haven't used the word vector
yes well well
we thought about that we also thought a
vector in matrix we also want an array
version of it which becomes problematic
okay
that they are they're symbolic things
not actual vectors
okay fair enough
okay so the point is that when you say
symbolic vector yeah i mean this is the
case you want symbolic vector plus a b
you want that to stay unevaluated
exactly and my branch does that
um
and i think this is actually you know
with with nice type setting for you know
symbolic vector um
then then i think this actually looks
reasonably nice we could put in a quote
x or a quote v or something in there
why there's a quote we'll talk about
that let's let's have a meeting what
does that mean we have to have a meeting
on it sometimes
sometime soon this is an important thing
um
by the way sandra is asking is threaded
nice and optimized
saying before often did transpose of
transpose but that's not nice memory
wise is threaded nice and optimized in
terms of its memory usage
not yet
but you know how to do that
yeah the mark mark mark mark mark is
working on it it's you know so for for
just
say matrices that are not packed raised
it's all it's all fine and optimized
it's also optimized for sparse arrays
um reasonably well but it's uh
but but the sort of the packed array
impact ray case
it's about a factor of two
okay okay more costly than it needs to
be
ethan is commenting a bit the thread
will be useful within function layers
yes
yes absolutely
um i think julia was excited about this
oh yeah because i mean this originally
came out of the machine learning group
the desire to do this all right okay so
anything more unthreaded right now
so coming back for a moment to your
previous question of of more threading
um there is this function that i added
to the version function repo
called array contract thread and that
that function
has the general case of threading
and that's the function from which all
of the functions can be derived
okay
so
i mean it's just this question of what's
the most general case of threading
and and in other languages they have an
a function called einstem which has the
same level of generality than this one
but they use indices and this uses
numbers
i see
so this is the generalization of inner
in some sense
of inner map thread
outer
all of them threaded even
will anybody ever understand it
that's why we moved it here because it
was considered too difficult when we
discussed it
but my point is that if there is a
discussion about of how to generalize a
threading
i would always point to this function
because in in scope or properties and
relations for example you see the i
think it's in in
properties and relations you see the
relations to all other functions right
and i mean at the point the point that
jose is making is that people do use
this in python this function in python
where it's called einsum only rather
than
using numbers you give it a string with
indices and dot dots and it parses that
string and turns it into a
uh
you know into into the appropriate
numbers based on the input
um and so you know okay so that's like a
regular expression type thing where
there's some kind of shorthand
string form which then gets turned into
something that can actually be
represented
more explicitly is that right
i don't know that i really
really call it regular expression oh
it's not actually regular expression but
it's like we have a function called
regular expression where you can type in
the regex syntax
i mean really it's just that they've
invented a syntax that isn't valid
python syntax for representing these and
that's what they're using
yeah and they're wrapping in a string
i would say it's just indices versus
numbers
but
where are the indices how do you define
what the indices
so so it's things like like
the string will be something like you
know i j arrow ji or something like that
right
so contract the first uh the first guy
uh the first index of the first tensor
with the last index of the second tensor
okay but that's what you're doing but
you instead of having an arrow here you
have a list here because you're allowing
an enery contraction yeah encountering
levels rather than saying i j k goes to
j j
k
things like that
well maybe we should have this function
i mean we might as well have a built-in
version i mean you know it seems like
this has already been written
is this efficient
it's not very efficient this was more
like an ex
an exercise of design rather than
efficiency
okay so the basic point
is f
and these are arrays and this is the
contraction pattern
right so there there are several
construct contractions potentially and
each of them is a list of numbers
indicating which levels of the
respective arrays are contracted
right and that could probably be a graph
too
yes this is like a graph yeah
but we could actually have a graph fed
into that argument
no at the moment no no no no i mean i
realize not now but in principle we
could have yes yes
and then for example the g
the g can be a list of functions because
the g is like they apply at each level
it's like having a different apply at
each level
the same as inner inner has an f and a g
the f is naturally times the g is
naturally plus
and then these these which i call
effective uh depths are like the
effective depths in outer these numbers
that we place
i understand that that's always a hack
in outer and it would be nice i mean
it's kind of like a partial symbolic
vector that you're saying
and i think when we talk about symbolic
spectrum maybe somebody can make sure we
remember that we need to talk about this
notion of a partial symbolic vector
that is something which is to be treated
as
symbolic below level such and such
but above level such and such it's still
a genuine array
exactly
um
well i think we should look at this
function some more and i think there
might be a way of making it
i mean
actually yeah go ahead i mean one
possible direction might be to to
instead of allow you know to allow in
addition to the list of lists of
integers
you know allow a string that's parsed
and yeah exactly exactly if there's a
reasonable thing to do there i mean also
these levels
okay something we've discussed but never
um
okay they're two level related things
one is the generalization of dot dot
to represent progressively deeper
functions in the pattern matcher
and the other is
essentially symbolic level names
like we have associations
for
you know we have the notion
of i'm going to put this in um just so
we keep it
um
oops didn't tally have something about
that but i'm not sure he ever
the thing about he's been claiming that
he has a future calculus of of um
uh array calculus and he's been telling
me
he's gonna tell us about it sometime
soon for a while
um
okay but but the the concept was okay so
here we've got
um
you know we also first of all we're
talking about symbolic vector
and partial symbolic vectors
and then we've got um
uh
head repeated
which is
in other words what matches
what matches that
is that what i mean
i think that's what i mean yes i think
so
um
we had also discussed f of bracket f of
bracket f when we were discussing
operators
yeah the forms
i mean not necessarily the same f but
but the idea of matching a head that has
so many brackets inside
right
i mean so the question is is head
repeated i mean i i look i'm not sure
that this is useful yet
um
but that's okay then the other thing we
were just talking about
oh gosh what were we just talking about
um
named levels
yes named levels right
okay so with association we have named
positions
right i think the name levels could
could be thought of in the context of
this data container yes i think so too
i mean in a sense association is our
minimal data container
yep
and uh
yeah okay
i mean
it is unclear what the syntax would look
like
for
right
yeah i i agree it probably has to be
some kind of container because i don't
see how to do it
otherwise okay
all right do we have a few moments to
look at um
so since we have ian and christopher
here i thought we could potentially talk
about implicit set a little bit um i
know that's a bigger topic so well i
think implicit set
or set builder whatever you're calling
it
second
instruction
or set construction perhaps i i hate the
word set being in there
um
and we can go back to like didn't
russell call it a collection
if it but how is it a collection of it's
with reals
did he call it a collection what did who
invented did did cantor invent the term
set
and what is it isn't it
in german what is it in german
that means number i think
um i'm not sure but i think that the
terminology like the term set is
surprisingly new
i mean cantor invented set theory so
what did he call it when he invented it
does anybody know
and try and look it up but
it does seem like if we had this this
set builder thing they're kind of a
whole bunch of functions you would
expect to
to return it or at least
i mean there are things like for example
you'd like a version of solve that
returns
you know a set of solutions for instance
yes you would
i mean but this is why we have
this rather
you know
rather i mean that's why reduce
does that
by just giving an alternate set of
conditions and creating variables to
represent things but it would be much
better if there was an implicit
you know constructor i mean this is
clearly also related to infinite lists
and lazy lists and so
on so by the way for for the naming
apparently uh cantor's original paper on
set theory was called on a property of
the collection of all real algebraic
numbers
in the modern mathematical parlance a
collection is more general than a set
right isn't it in the pure map exactly
we also had class builder where you
didn't have domains for the variables
that's obscure
yes it is
but strictly speaking you you can't
have
a proper set builder notation without
having domains for the variables
the axioms define sets in terms of
subsets of existing sets
if you believe in the whole axiomatic
thing um
but okay so
but i mean this this is surely deeply
related to infinite lists because these
are essentially lists
whose elements are
being generated by some kind of function
or generator or criterion well lists
have multiplicity and an order
yeah they have an order and to me the
that sounds countable
meaning okay all right so so this is
compare okay so
compare to infinite lists
which which are ordered
and countable
i mean these could be countable too they
could be over the integers
right they could be but there's an
example right there of an of an
uncountable one
right in terms of naming
we could call it you know integer set
i mean isn't it the case
that
really just not a set a set to me
conveys unordered
yeah
and it would be an integer sequence
yeah
well i'm sorry what what's this
sequences conveying what i think
stephen's conveying with integer
no i didn't mean that i meant integer
set what i meant was that the base
assumption about the variables is that
they're integers
i mean i don't know whether this makes
sense but i mean something like i mean
is it the case it seems kind of horrible
why not just
i mean
why
integers
if we're talking about lists like it
could be lists of anything
well yes
then we're gonna have complexes and then
we're gonna have quaternions set and
we're gonna have you know you know all
these are never had a built-in
okay but the point is that that this
idea
you know you said axioms and you meant
it because you you know to set up this
kind of implicit set
you have to have some base
i know i'm using different words in
different places here but some base
domain in which you're operating
and that's what separates naive set
theory from set theory exactly
yeah
explain more in more detail
i mean in naive set theory you can just
say you know give me the set of all x's
that satisfy this but but basically
because of this this this leads to
russell's paradox problems and so the
solution is that you only allow yourself
to to build sets through i forget what
it's called in in zf there's a name of
the axiom it's basically lets you do set
builder notation to say give me all this
the set of all x's
such you know
it was set
yeah
so
frankl choice axioms
dfc
yes
it's not choice so so
class builder was exactly the the thing
where you want to define a collection of
things just in terms of a predicate
just give me everything that satisfies
some predicate
you have
consistency issues with that
yes fine
right
hence
well
okay but the main point here is that an
implicit
list set whatever
i mean the question of sets in general
you know we don't even have
a notion of a
thing you carry around that
automatically like an association
automatically removes duplicate keys
we don't have that notion for a thing
that automatically reduce removes
duplicate elements
or even the automatic
the the finite set you mean yes we don't
have i mean you know the other thing we
could have is orderless list
and we've talked about having an
orderless list
i don't know multi-set
yes
the orderless list and
a version of list where you get rid of
duplicates
yeah i know but the the problem is
distinct from orderless list
indeed i mean that would be more like a
an auto unioning list otherwise known as
a set
well um
auto delete duplicates
right
well i think it would also union like
you said is like a set
yeah but that's that's yet a different
case are you talking about the case
where where you delete the duplicates
but you leave the order the same yes
which is which is by the way what what
happens to the keys of associations
exactly
yes
um although i i argue that that case is
not terribly useful i mean i think the
main case that that people care about is
the unordered sets
or or maybe unordered multi-sets
but but if you want to multi-set you can
already represent multisets pretty
reasonably using associations
right i mean i don't think i mean the
orderless list concept
has just not been a serious thing i mean
people use union they use delete
duplicates they use sort
it hasn't been if it was more efficient
i mean i i don't know there have been
plenty of times when i mean
i i'm not sure i think there there might
be times when if it was significantly
more performant in the same way that
association is a lot more performant
than lists of rules then i think it
might be useful but association has a
lot of ancillary stuff like the whole
selector mechanism
all those kinds of things that are like
for example an orderless list
what happens if you ask for the 10th
elements of an orderless list does it
just behave like an ordinary list or
does it do something different
i would predict it has some ordering
like like it
it has some canonical ordering or
something or maybe even an arbitrary
ordering
but but i think that the other problem
with introducing a thing that's like a
set
would be that
when when we introduced association
there were some functions that returned
lists of rules and was kind of like okay
well it's unfortunate but there'll be
just some functions that still return
list of rules but most of the newer you
know most of the functions
were you know only came in afterward and
returned associations if you get what i
mean but but here there's a ton of
functions that conceptually return sets
that we already have
and we couldn't switch them
right
right are these things like
i think orderless list and union list
are more like data structures
whereas
what we were using set builder for in
the pure math pack that was just kind of
symbolic representations for math
and these seem like two different cases
right yeah it's not clear to me why
we're discussing both of these things
right
well because i i thought that
infinite lists which are produced with a
generator
are related to
the set builder thing well there's
certain first of all there's some
countability
problems and second of all there's the
fact that i mean at least all the
different you know they're they're five
different you know infinite list things
that they've been discussed recently but
i mean all of them
are pretty much all of them
uh
it's it's kind of cons it's very uh you
know constructionist like you you you
tell it how to get the elements as
opposed to giving it like a condition or
something
are you thinking of like
um
like a sequence
like the sequence of f n where n is
integers
for what purpose you're saying for the
infinite list case yeah well i'm saying
you know you can have an infinite range
and then you say select
you know you you would say something
like
uh
selectively
right there's one where you you you have
you can directly generate the nth
element and there's the one where you
need to generate elements one through n
minus one in order to generate the nth
element
yeah and set builder is more like
generate the int element directly
okay this is in set builder
instead of sequences
yeah this is this is both
i think infant lists are really pretty
distinct both because you know they're
they're count they're kind of implicitly
countable and because i think this is
much more of a programming concept for
doing things like streams and and stuff
like that than it is a pure math concept
okay
but i mean okay but this set builder
thing
uh
what does the pure math wait what is the
pure math backlit
that contains
like the topology entity store
in the other entity stores
which we should talk about and review
sometime soon
i'm not sure what our strategy is in
that area
do we understand what it is
pretty much
it's on hold
okay
but maybe we should discuss it and just
see whether there's a
you know whether there's low-hanging
fruit we can pick from it
could probably start by putting it in
the paclet repository
that would seem like a good thing to do
i mean i'm i'm pretty ignorant of what's
there
and i mean i don't know what point the
topology stuff that's there coincides
with topology stuff that the
computational geometry team is doing
i think it's unlikely
okay
okay
but i mean i also just definitions and
theorems
okay
well as we start thinking more about you
know find equational proof and theorem
representations and so on
there may yet be
some commonality there i'd at least like
to understand it
and we have hopefully in the next week
or so we have a thing coming up talking
about category theory representing
category theory
in the language and i don't know how
that relates to any of this stuff
um
all right i think we're getting to be
over time here let's just have a little
bit of a look at what we
replace so the first one is poorly named
but it's basically a method of doing
replace all with an exception pattern
why don't we give replace all an
exception pattern well that would kind
of be the a natural place to do it if
that's something we think
integrates well with it
you know do we want isn't it essentially
an accept i mean on the left hand side
of the rule
um
yeah
what's the difference between this
what's that
yeah i
well
it looks like for the example it doesn't
go inside of anything with head f
yeah
well so that's more of a traversal order
exception
which could affect map and things like
that as well
i mean that's something we should
discuss in connection with traversal
orders which is something we're talking
about in this multi-computation thing we
should
have that because this idea of a of a
protected
you know protection from further
traversal
which is what this is as i understand it
correct if i understand it correctly i
mean it's similar to the excluded forms
option
in various mathematical functions
is it not
i think we would do this by prepending
a rule
underscore f goes to itself
to the other
yeah i understand that's a
i mean that seems a bit hacky but yes i
understand that but there's also the
question of just saying
for map
you know what should you exclude from
the map because it's often convenient
for code i mean otherwise you have to
say if
you know for example
let's imagine that you could say
something like um
map
f over list
with um
something like that
otherwise for example let's say this
map at level 2 with excluded forms
failure means just don't do it if you
run into that subpart of the expression
see what i'm saying
i mean i certainly would have used this
many times but there may be a better way
to do it i mean
um
uh
all right i mean you can you you can do
that oh hold on this is map sorry
you see you've gone there is that thing
there is that thing maybe i should i
should really look at this again but
there are those constructs um
you see they're called that that we
talked about a year ago and then a few
weeks ago
um that were sort of for dealing with
kind of this case
how where were they put i mean and
let me see i'll get the information
about them but but it was for i think it
was for kind of dealing with this case
of
of if you you kind of have one level of
error propagation that you want
okay but the other possibility here or
something was one one of we had a couple
of i don't remember the names off the
top of my head one of them i think was
replace failure and one of them was to
extend missing queue with
sort of more types of arguments or
failures
i think one thing that we discussed was
i think test applied but that one we
didn't come to some conclusion about
yeah
so the idea is you you'd give it a
function and then you'd give it failure
q and it would only apply it if it was
not failure q or something
what about something like this
where you put a wrapper around a
function
and you say exclude from the traversal
things that match that you know that
that have that that have that fact so
this is this is the same as the test
applied although it's more of a match
applied so basically what it would be
map wouldn't need any special behavior
and also you wouldn't put it around the
list you'd put it around the f right and
all you do is you just
this would be a function where
if if the it's the equivalent to if
match q of hash comma the pattern then
hash otherwise f hash
i know that's what i was thinking here
and i agree that that's useful but that
doesn't do this thing about switch off
the rodent identification
that would need special behavior in map
well maybe in map not in replace all
right because once you've replaced it no
i agree it replaced all it wouldn't i i
worry that adding something i mean i
understand you're basically saying that
you have an object that basically
represents a list but where you're going
to ignore
missing things in the list or failures
in the list i think there are two
problems the first problem is that the
the policy about whether you want to see
the missings or not that is a function
specific policy not a list specific
policy right some functions want them
missing some functions don't the other
thing is that uh
i feel like whenever you introduce these
sort of
objects like that the time it takes them
to actually get supported in all the
places that they need to be supported
it's long enough that it's just it's
it's a pain i kind of agree
i mean look i had a bug yesterday that
was rather hard to find that involved
position
that had been going into
you know digging into things where
i would have liked to treat as atomic
certain aspects of those things
um
well with position i mean i
yeah i mean i feel like more often the
problem with position is just the fact
that it's default is head's hero true
level spec
uh
infinity isn't it yes it is and that's
you know
i feel like the most common case is is
actually the default for i think count
has the
quotes the correct default which is the
countdown has zero false right
let's find expressions find some
expressions together they're positions
i see what is this now as a nick
production
um
find all sub-expressions
okay find subject versions that match
what is this
it's not the best of designs but it
tries to cover
most of the cases when you want to
restrict by
both pattern and the position
and just oh i suggest
i search aside
that's a okay so that's a
different well it depends what you mean
by restrict by position because i mean
the thing we're talking about with map
is
you know look the case with map
is you hit a failure you don't want to
burrow inside the failure
or you hit some kind of object that you
want to treat as atomic
you know it's kind of like
this is only for level specs greater
than one you mean
yes
yes that's correct
i mean it's like like
look it would be
treat as atomic
anything with head h
and don't go inside it
yeah so in that sub-expression positions
that would be outer match except
like
each
underscore what is another
and a match means what's below you
know yeah inner march would be what
below evil and how too much outside of
it so if you want to restrict going
deep inside of something then you
may quite
and now too much accept so that it
doesn't match anything inside
that has this head outside anywhere
outside of it so if you all the
positions inside failure would
would not
be valid in this case so basically the
idea is as you descend into an
expression
you know stop
if you see
if you
fail
the outer match
is that right
it's like
you fail if anything outside this
expression matches your pattern
yeah i get it but i mean you could think
of it as as in
in the case of map okay that's a
different thing where you could say
that's that's essentially that is the
analog of of context quotes
context dependent patterns
so we could imagine something where we
say
you know f of x blank goes to x squared
but only do that if
the um
uh
if
there's no
g
anywhere
higher up in the expression
that's the kind of thing you're saying i
think
just saying do a replace all but with
the constraint that that replacement is
only done if there's no g
uh
anywhere higher up in the expression or
something
okay there's more to figure out about
this this this idea of excluded forms
from map is something we should look at
some more
and um
uh
yeah
and i think it's time to wrap up for now
um
so
progress is being made slowly i i'm i'm
excited that um
uh
um
we're we seem to be re-exploring a bunch
of language issues which have been
uh long
dormant so to speak
so that's exciting as far as i'm
concerned
uh all right well thanks folks here
thanks to folks on the live stream and